- Here's a pro tip.
Don't ask to go on vacation in Jamaica
if you're on trial for
storming the Capitol
in one of the funniest minute orders ever.
Well here, I'll just read it to you.
This is straight from the judge.
"Defendant, while on pretrial
release and facing charges
including a serious felony offense
stemming from his alleged
actions on January 6th, 2021,
wishes to leave the Michigan
winter to spend 10 days
in the warmer climes of Jamaica
to meet the family of a woman
with whom defendant has been
in a committed relationship.
Although such a meeting
may be an important step
in defendant's personal relationship,
defendant surrendered his entitlement
to unfettered international
travel when also,
'He allegedly announced his
intent to' storm the swamp.
And one week later on January 6th, 2021
followed through by joining
a mob at the Capitol,
that in his words 'took
that (beep) building,'
an event he allegedly viewed as the
'proudest day of his life.'
This court will not commemorate
the one year anniversary
of this attack on the Capitol
by granting defendant's request
for non-essential foreign travel."
Signed by Chief Judge Beryl A. Howell.
Dang!